hey guys Pete here one of the things
that was really frustrating in the lead
up to season 3 or the return of Twin
Peaks was the lack of trailers and new
footage that we could break apart and
try to you know speculate on what was
going to happen that's all in the rear
view mirror at this point I did what is
kind of frustrating now is that there
are no scenes that they kind of have for
the next episode before it airs when the
first four episodes were four parts
dropped I figured maybe this was you
know something that they obviously
wouldn't make trailers for the next one
because more or less they were all
available but I was hoping at the end of
part four that we would get something to
give us an idea of what to look forward
to and discussed in the week before
episode five finally came out so that
didn't happen and I would assume that
this is going to be the norm I don't
know why they would start to do it
midway through so I came across the post
I'm reading about a week ago where they
looked at the trailers that already
existed the three brief trailers that we
saw new footage in and which scenes we
hadn't seen yet so today I'm going to
look at those and see if there's
anything that we can glean out of what's
to come and it was actually kind of
surprising because I thought that we saw
most of the stuff when I first saw the
post and then I realized that yeah we
did see quite a few things but there's a
bunch of stuff we haven't seen yet the
redditor absurd living ghost put this
together and the first teaser was the
one that was very short there's a couple
scenes and we actually haven't seen
quite a few things from this one now the
first one that's pointed out is the
person walking through the puddle with
the reflection of the bang-bang bar side
so you have the Roadhouse we have scene
but we have not seen this particular
part and it seems like an interesting
clip because it kind of gives us an idea
that some that were following someone
into the Roadhouse rather than just
cutting there to watch a video or you
know whatever a musical performance the
next was the exterior shot of the
doubler cafe and this reminds me that we
haven't seen much of Twin Peaks at all
outside of
Sheriff's Department the next one is the
one that I'm most interested in and that
is the shot of that trout trailer park
now why I'm interested is because this
was obviously an interesting place and
fire walk with me it was in Deer meadow
and it may have moved we don't really
know for sure the sign looks the same
and it has the word new attached at the
top but we don't know how long ago that
was added or even a scientist to be in a
different place call rod you know he was
mentioned in the secret history we found
out that he was abducted as a child with
the log lady and so he's very
interesting character and you know he
may have moved the trailer park after
the deer meadow thing went down if you
have any thoughts about this let me know
in the comments it's one of those
strange inconsistencies that exist in
the secret history and the shows so I
really don't know for sure
but what I assume considering that
Oregon is south of Washington and that
since Twin Peaks is near the Canadian
border that they must have completely
moved the fat trap trailer park to
somewhere closer to Twin Peaks if not
into Twin Peaks itself that at the end
of this we had a shot of the Palmer
House that looked like it was likely
filmed from a car it's kind of shaky and
it's clearly someone it's sort of
voyeuristic looking so if someone's
looking at the house from a distance and
the assumption was that it was from a
car the second trailer with new footage
was the 25 years later one and it showed
us a lot of the old characters the first
thing we saw was Big Ed Hurley sitting
at a desk there's a stuffed bear kind of
head on the desk next to him he looks he
looks so conflicted or deep in thought
at the very least we haven't seen big ad
at all so we really don't know where
this fits into the sequence of things
the next one was called rod who I was
just talking about sitting on a bench
he looks somewhat terrified in my
opinion and I imagine this has something
to do
it's what you know basically what he
said that in fire walk with me that he's
been places which has been tied together
through the secret history that he's our
you know he's basically been abducted by
what we would call aliens I guess then
we had to shot a Sarah Palmer shopping
for liquor at the grocery store not much
on this that we can read except for that
she has a cart she's in the liquor
aisles
the only thing that's really in there
looks like some kind of treats and some
Bloody Mary Mix so we have seen her in
the returned already and she was at home
drinking so we kind of get the idea that
that's probably one of her you know
that's probably one of her favorite
pastimes if not something she does on a
daily basis it's really odd when you
think about her and the fact that she
stayed in that house after all that
stuff happened but I'm sure we're going
to learn more about her let me get a
shot of Andy standing outside of a
police car with the door open we don't
really know where he's at but he you
know he looks startled or intrigued by
something we get a shot of hawk and he
says really which I'm pretty sure we
haven't seen that yet and then there's a
shot of Cooper which had you know it's
been pointed out that there's some
blonde hair on the very side of the
frame so he looks to be with a blonde
but you can't really tell what that
means it is who we assume is the good
coop the original Agent Dale Cooper at
least by the way he looks but we really
don't know for sure if or when he's
going to be back to his old self
the third teaser was that it's happening
again teaser that was the very last one
before the season started we got a sort
of a horror show kind of beginning to
this teaser has a stairway that's all
shaky it looks supernatural in some way
or another if you look closely you kind
of see that the walls are painted sort
of like patch painted that it looks like
a place I don't know where it's supposed
to be but we definitely haven't seen
this yet there's another shot of Cooper
we haven't seen yet and he's walking
from the back it's not a hundred percent
clear whether he's in
the real world or somewhere else but it
kind of looks like he's in a city
setting and yeah that's about it it's
very shadowy and we can't really tell
other than he's obviously walking we got
a picture of Andy he's closing a door to
the you know a car and he's holding a
picnic basket and again it looks like
he's looking at something that seems to
be a recurring sort of theme throughout
all these shots of the old characters is
that they're you know they're looking or
they're thinking about something and you
know we're supposed to just insist
mysterious we don't know there's another
shot of the Roadhouse here with people
hanging out it this could have been in
there I don't know we have seen the
Roadhouse a couple of times really only
ones from outside but I didn't go back
and check this one and then the last one
is this probably mode I'm second most
excited about and I kind of totally
forgot about this until I saw this post
on Reddit but we do get a shot of what
appears to be the good agent Dale Cooper
driving at night now originally when
this came out we didn't realize there
were other Cooper's and that there were
was going to be a time when Cooper
wasn't all himself but I kind of think
that it's unlikely since evil coupe is
now locked up in the federal prison that
he's going to be able to get out and
then end up impersonating the good Dale
like in the beginning I thought oh you
know whenever he got the car and
whatever that he would probably be going
back to Twin Peaks to take up
impersonating Cooper again but when he
landed in jail that kind of seemed to
derail that theory or that you know that
storyline but we really don't know
because right now the real coop is not
really all there and who knows how long
it's going to take I mean it may take
more than one cup of coffee for him to
start to bounce back especially if what
we had talked about in previous videos
the fact that both of them being in the
world at the same time seems to be
causing problems one thing we do know is
that there will be some coupon coop
pylons at some point those two
characters Mike lays out pretty clearly
that one of them
has to die how we get to that point is
going to be fun and we don't really know
how but I'm sure it'll be worth the ride
and what do you guys think about this
stuff do you think it tells us anything
do you think that it's surprising that
there's still this many things I think
like most of the stuff we saw was we saw
Sam and Tracy we saw the woman in South
Dakota with the Chihuahua you know we
saw a lot of new character stuff that's
all been done but what we haven't really
seen a lot of is the original cast
members like Andy and Cara the double
are all that stuff we haven't really
seen any of that stuff yet that we saw
in these trailers so that's pretty
exciting I mean a lot of people have
been asking is it ever going to get back
to Twin Peaks and I think the answer is
a resounding yes it's just how's it
going to get there and what's going to
happen there is really the big questions
so let me know in the comments what you
think what do you think about the fact
that there aren't you know upcoming seat
you know scenes from the upcoming show
it's kind of a bummer that's something I
like to do is break those things down
trailer breakdowns and things so we're
yeah let me know please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already like the
video if you found it interesting and
check back because I will be doing more
twin peaks' videos real soon thanks for
watching I'll talk to you again